This is Atlanta, Georgia.
It's my hometown.
It's also where I became a sports fan.
I played some sports as
a kid and I love sports.
In fact, my first real job in journalism
was covering the 1996 Olympic Games.
I've changed a lot since then.
You can see it in my hairline alone.
But the city has too,
especially in Downtown Atlanta
which remains the epicenter
of sports in Atlanta.
The Hawks play within steps of The Falcons
and the college football
hall of fame is right
across Centennial Park.
Georgia Tech plays football at one
of the oldest stadiums in
the NCAA, just up the street.
And all of this is located in
the heart of Fulton County.
You probably heard that name a few times
in the recent elections.
Fulton County.
From Fulton County.
A big part of that difference
is in these counties,
in this Metro Atlanta area.
A solidly red state for almost 30 years,
back to when Bill Clinton
was first elected,
Georgia was suddenly in play in 2020
and record voter turnout
ultimately played a key role
in determining the balance of
power in the United States.
But if you were living
in Atlanta last summer,
record-setting voting
seemed unlikely at best.
Seems like this, playing out
across Fulton County, Tuesday
starting early in the morning,
extending through midnight.
The June ninth primary
election is a primary example
of systematic depression that the people
of this County still face.
But far from disaster,
Fulton County became a model
of turnout and voter efficiency.
Along the way creating one of
the largest voting precincts
in the history of the United States.
At the heart of the effort,
Atlanta sports franchises and athletes.
And while some owners would
open their doors literally
and figuratively to activism,
others would oppose it
and end up losing their teams altogether.
When you own a sports franchise,
hopefully any business,
but certainly a sports franchise,
you have an obligation to try
to be relevant to the public
and to the community you operate in.
And that's actually good business
and the right thing to do.
They just literally feel
a culture shift happening.
I felt like I was just
excited to be a part
of a city that stands for something.
By now we all know the results
of those key elections,
but behind the scenes were
a series of crucial moves.
I wanted to hear from the
people who made those decisions
and who once again, turned Atlanta
into a microcosm of race,
politics and sports.
Now look, I know Atlanta
doesn't boast the championships
of New York, Boston or LA,
it's nowhere close, sadly,
but Atlanta's long been a sports town
and the history of its athletes and teams,
well it's inextricably tied
to its central role in
the Civil Rights Movement.
Well, in my days in Atlanta as a child,
there was a pretty strict
system of segregation.
The birthplace of Martin Luther King, Jr.
And the home to luminaries
such as Andrew Young
and the late Congressman John Lewis.
Atlanta which once built itself,
the city too busy to hate,
has also been home to
some of the most exciting,
legendary and controversial
sports figures, franchises
and events of the past 50 years.
In 2020 with sports largely sidelined
by the global pandemic,
those Downtown Atlanta
teams didn't fare so well
even if there was no one there to see it.
The Hawks missed the playoffs
again and The Falcons, well,
they found new ways to lose,
but on those same courts and fields,
both athletes and owners may
generation defining decisions.
Now I wish I could take
you back to Atlanta,
show you all of this myself,
but the global pandemic
won't allow for that either.
So I'm going to do the best that I can
from here in my daughter's
bedroom, in New York.
Okay, so let's look at the players here.
Here's Downtown Atlanta.
This is State Farm Arena,
it's where The Hawks play.
They're owned by a group
led by investor Tony Ressler
and his family.
The CEO is a native Atlantan
and longtime Coca-Cola
and Turner broadcasting
executive named Steve Koonin.
And up until recently,
the head coach of The
Hawks was Lloyd Pierce.
He's part of a new generation
of young activists NBA leaders.
All three of these men played a huge role
in turning the stadium
into a voting center.
Nearby is the giant newly
constructed Mercedes-Benz stadium.
This is where the Atlanta Falcons
along with major league soccer's
Atlanta United, both owned
by Home Depot co-founder
Arthur Blank, play their games.
It too would become an early voting center
in the Senate runoff elections.
Of course where to vote was critical,
but so too is getting people motivated.
And that's where the
city's athletes came in,
spurred by local leaders,
as well as the activist
heritage of Atlanta.
Few played a more notable role
than WNBA star Renee Montgomery.
She gave up a year of
playing for the Atlanta Dream
in order to partner with
activist groups like Fair Fight
and More Than a Vote.
We'll get into all of that,
but where this story really
starts is late May of 2020
with the killing of George Floyd.
If there ain't no justice.
No peace.
Black lives matter, black lives matter.
Breonna Taylor gets shot
and killed in her own home.
Ahmaud Arbery gets shot and killed
while he's simply going
on a jog down Georgia.
George Floyd is choked
out and lynched on camera
in front of all of us to
witness live and in person.
And you have, you know,
millions of black people,
young black people in particular,
all around this country
who are upset or angry or frustrated.
This is Michael Tyler.
He also grew up in Atlanta
and now he's the executive vice-president
of More Than a Vote.
That's a group started
by LeBron James in 2020
to mobilize voters by tapping
athletes and entertainers
to spread the word, city
by city and state by state.
I want a righteous anger.
The key is to be able
to channel that anger.
I think a lot of the athletes themselves
felt the exact same way.
I think what it did was
crystallize for all of us the need
to form an organization like this,
realizing that the best way to fight back
in this moment and to
create a more just society
for our communities is
through the electoral process.
When I think back to the summer of 2020,
I just think back to all
the passion in the city.
You know, I was out there giving waters
and having cookouts for the protesters.
There was a lot of
energy and I'm like, man,
we gotta make sure that
all these people vote.
Renee Montgomery's a two
time WWE NBA champion
and as of last summer,
she was the point guard
for the Atlanta Dream.
But in June she announced
she would opt out
of the 2020 season, deciding
to dedicate her time
to social justice and a big part
of her message was
relatively simple, vote.
Big news this week
when Atlanta Dream guard Renee Montgomery
announced she was going to skip
the upcoming 2022 WNBA season.
I started to realize when
people are asking me,
are you excited about
this upcoming season?
And I was like, I hadn't
even been thinking about it.
That started to trigger my
mind and maybe I need to follow
you know, where my mind
is and where my heart is.
I mean, it's not, it is not
a light decision at all.
I mean, and listen, I'm
not a professional athlete,
you are, but I can only imagine that like,
you've got your routine,
you know what you gotta do,
you literally know the steps
you have to take to get there,
to get the brass ring.
This path is not so
clear in terms of like,
how do you get people out to vote?
What do they do?
How did you go about saying, all right,
this is how I spend my time.
These are the projects that I wanna do?
For me, I wanna help,
but I wanna make sure
that I'm like helping in the right way.
So I don't wanna just be
out there doing anything,
I wanted to make sure that, you know,
the messaging was what it should
be and that it was correct,
it was factual and I had to lean on people
that know what they're doing.
So that's a More Than a Vote.
I remember Renee reaches out,
she reached out to me personally via email
and said, hey Michael, I
don't know if you've heard,
I had heard, but I chose to step away
from basketball full time.
I have to focus exactly
on these sorts of efforts.
So, you know, whatever it
is that you need me to do,
I'm all in.
Since that day, she has become
one of our top advocates
for all of our work,
particularly down in Georgia,
in Atlanta, which was ground zero
for many of our efforts
in the general election.
But with the pandemic in
full force all around her,
boots on the ground was largely virtual.
And Montgomery said about mobilizing
and motivating from her home.
I know differences in
opinions on how to handle it
and what to do, whatever
you do, just be safe.
Protect you, protect your neighbor.
We don't wanna hurt anybody.
Keep the energy going.
Make it peaceful, but keep
it going, let's not stop.
A room in her house would
get fully converted,
equipped with cameras, lighting,
even space for photo
shoots and music recording.
I have major studio envy.
Like if you could see
like where I am, I'm like,
I'm actually in my daughter's bedroom.
And I have like Anna and Elsa
over here, like it's just.
Oh, you trying to build a
snowman over there, okay.
You clearly have it down.
Listen, this is the, welcome
to the new normal, right?
Like this is the office, right?
My home has become the studio.
That means like for video,
this is where I film
TMZ Sports at every day,
right here in our studio.
So it's kind of crazy to think about.
My podcast is called Remotely Renee
because I had to figure out
how to do everything remotely.
Montgomery would also create initiatives
around increasing involvement
in local politics.
She raised money to
improve education at HBCUs
and spoke to a lot of people about voting.
What do you tell young people
and how are you encouraging
them to get out there,
register and vote?
One of the things
that are gonna tackle
is voter suppression.
As you spoke about earlier,
I'm here in Georgia.
So that's my connection,
and my strong tie with .
I'm excited to get things going
with More Than a Vote campaign.
I've heard people tell
me I'm not into politics,
but I wanna remind them.
You may not be into politics,
but politics is into you.
It decides whether you
make a minimum wage.
get a stimulus check.
It decides whether you get charged
with a misdemeanor or felony.
For Renee and for these
athletes who are at large,
it speaks to their understanding
of the power of their own voice.
And they know that no matter
how individually they choose
to leverage it, they
know that there's power.
You know, it's synonymous
with the way that LeBron
thinks about things too.
When she stepped away, she
knew what she cared about.
She knew what she wanted to
do, but she wanted to make sure
that she had a specific plan of action
for how she was actually
going to execute her activism.
At least speaking
out on issues off the field or court
hasn't always been well-received.
Look no further than the way fans,
national politicians and the
media treated Colin Kaepernick.
After he spoke out
against racial injustice,
he couldn't get a job,
despite being considered one
of the top players at his position.
LeBron of course was
famously told to quote,
shut up and dribble, back in 2018,
but his refusal to back down,
along with a growing chorus
of black athletes, especially
in the WNBA and the NBA ensure
that activism would be an integral part
of their professional lives.
Athletes are able to communicate
with other young black people in a way
that no politician can ever do.
They're able to lay out mistakes
and lay out their personal motivations
in a way that is going to resonate
with other young black
voters that is simply unique.
And so when you have an entire coalition
of athletes doing that,
it becomes, you know, force
multiplier within our community
and, you know, speaks to
the importance of voting
in a way that simply nobody else can.
But while Montgomery was
working to get out the vote,
those newly inspired folks had
to have somewhere to show up
and vote and safely,
given the global pandemic.
Today, voters in Georgia were met
with long lines and
confusion at polling places
as they tried to cast ballots
in the state's primary elections.
From the air, you could see
long lines of Georgia voters,
socially distanced, stretching
through parking lots.
They hold the line,
the machines don't work
and we're just stuck here.
Thousands waited hours to cast ballots
and frustration was evident.
Please God, help us.
Fulton County being the largest county
in the state of Georgia,
therefore we're the
focal point to anything
that goes right or wrong.
This is Rob Pitts.
He's the chairman of Fulton
County Board of Commissioners.
Elected go wrong in those
early June primaries
and in a state with a long
history of voter suppression,
long wait lines disproportionately
affected black citizens.
For Chairman Pitts, the
pandemic was creating
both a health and a political crisis.
Many of the precincts that
we had historically used
and traditionally used
because of the Coronavirus,
they'd said, well you can
no longer use our facility
because we are afraid.
Many of the workers who were
going to work on election day,
in fact, six out of
seven at the last minute,
decided that they were not gonna work
because they were afraid.
A primary vote is one thing,
but one deck was a critical
series of elections.
A runoff, a generationally
important presidential election
and not one but two US Senate races.
And tensions only increased
as a city long accustomed
to complicated racial politics took part
in a national reckoning around
inequality and injustice
Tonight, anger and frustration in Atlanta.
Crowds gathering outside
the fire gutted Wendy's
where 27 year old Rayshard Brooks was shot
and killed by police
during an attempted arrest.
Within 24 hours, Atlanta's
police chief stepped down.
The officer who shot Brooks was fired,
and the other officer involved placed
on administrative duty.
The protest, they really
happened at the nexus
of where our arena is, Marietta street
and Centennial Olympic
Park, right on the park.
Next to CNN is our building.
This is Steve Koonin.
He's the CEO of the Atlanta
Hawks and State Farm Arena.
And in watching these protests,
I was just struck with the passion.
I was struck with the peaceful way
that these young people
were out protesting.
And to me, the only action,
the only change that ever
comes is with voting.
The most powerful thing
you can do is vote.
And at the time, we were
sitting on an empty arena.
No basketball, no concerts, no shows,
but we had something in
our arena that is rare.
You can find it very few places
in that state, 700,000 square feet.
We actually were sitting around again,
there were others involved,
and I guess as the owner,
you get to take credit
for things that you really
didn't do or think of.
So I'd be on that category, but
we were trying to figure out
how can we help the community?
This is the owner of
The Hawks, Tony Ressler.
He made his fortune through Ares Capital,
an investing firm he created in the 1990s.
He put together a group to
buy The Hawks back in 2015,
and while this main
residence is in Los Angeles,
he and his wife,
the actress Jamie Gertz have
become hands-on team owners.
Why not use the arena
as a voting location,
as a voting location.
We weren't sure we could do it.
And frankly, we weren't sure
Fulton County would permit us
to do it.
I absolutely remember getting
a call and phone rang.
I have a flip phone, I have to .
It rang and on the other hand
was my good friend, Steve Koonin.
So he said, well look, we're dark,
there are no games playing here.
We'd like to be being a
good corporate citizen.
We would like to find out and
to know if there is a role
that we at the Atlanta Hawks
and State Farm Arena can play.
And I said Steve, let me get back to you.
So in less than five minutes,
I got back to him and I
said, okay we got a deal.
Today officials from Fulton County
and the Atlanta Hawks
announced the opening
of Georgia's largest early voting precinct
at State Farm Arena.
The plan is to use it starting July 20th
in the primary runoff
as well as for the fall general election.
I think we caught everybody off guard.
And I think as soon as you hear the idea,
you kind of go, well that makes sense.
I mean, it's so simple.
This is not rocket science
of an idea, it's simple.
So the plan was the then
empty State Farm Arena
would be turned into what was known
as a super polling location.
Meaning anyone in Fulton
County would be able to come
to the arena to vote.
The court at the arena would be dedicated
to socially distanced voting machines,
100 machines for the July runoff election
and then tripling to 300
for the general election in November.
Conference rooms would be converted
for poll workers to process
votes, including mail-in voting.
The Hawks Foundation
would also provide 1,500
free parking spots
in the surrounding area
to accommodate voters.
And in addition to the site,
The Hawks added a critical piece,
some 350 full-time staffers,
200 of whom would be deputized
as poll workers.
When you see election
problems, most of the time,
it's because it's a
volunteer staff of people
who don't have the
capability or the experience.
We're in the customer service business.
We know how to resolve issues.
We're in the hospitality business,
we're in the security business.
So everybody felt highly
comfortable, quickly
that we had the capability to do this.
You need employee buy-in
to make this work.
And the one thing that none of us want
to acknowledge is the fear factor.
You know, you commit your building
and you become a worse polling location.
You become a mess,
you become a four-hour
wait and a disaster.
Let's not kid ourselves,
that hurts your franchise,
that hurts your business.
That hurts your employee morale.
But while the owners
of The Hawks were busy creating
a super polling location,
another basketball owner in Atlanta
was making their own headlines.
And it WNBA news,
Atlanta Dream co-owner Kelly
Loeffler is not in favor
of the WNBA social justice plans.
And Loeffler has sent a letter
to commissioner Cathy Engelbert objecting
to the league's initiatives
to honor the Black Lives Matter movement.
And Kelly Loeffler, of course,
wasn't just the co-owner
of the Atlanta Dream,
she was running to keep her seat
as a US Senator from Georgia.
Loeffler was objecting
to a league decision
to allow players to wear
black warm-up jerseys
with the words black lives
matter and say her name on them.
In a letter to the league's commissioner,
Loeffler argued that instead,
they should place an American
flag on every Jersey.
And she stated that
there needs to be less,
not more politics in sports.
For the Atlanta Dream for myself,
you know, we saw where
we wanted to take a stand
and just, and we did it.
Last night, Elizabeth Williams,
along with several teammates and players
from other WNBA teams
wore a vote Warnock shirt.
It was a very carefully
crafted message in support
of US Senate candidate,
Reverend Raphael Warnock.
Players from every team
in the WNBA would go on
to wear shirts saying vote Warnock.
So here, we've got to pause to marvel
at a hard to make up
element of this story.
The owner of a team
named to a vote the work
of the late Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
effectively turned the
team against herself
to the point where that
team endorsed her opponent.
That opponent had the same job,
pastor of the famed
Ebeneezer Baptist Church
that the late Dr. King
and his father once held.
But the Reverend Raphael Warnock was part
of what they call a
non-partisan blanket primary.
Part of a crowded field
looking to challenge Loeffler.
And according to research
by the Washington Post,
the exposure helped
boost Warnock's campaign
at a critical time.
48 hours after the WNBA players
started to wear his name,
the campaign raised $183,000
and attracted 3,500 new grassroots donors.
And by the time the election
in November rolled around,
Warnock was the only real
challenger left for Loeffler.
We did our homework and
we used our platforms
and those are the same
platforms that a lot of people
you know, they tried to overlook,
but we all band together
and we use our platforms
for something that we believe in.
And it was only a few weeks
after the WNBA players endorsed Warnock
that NBA athletes would grab
the sports world's attention.
The Milwaukee Bucks
have reportedly decided
to boycott game five
against the Orlando Magic
in protest of the police
shooting of Jacob Blake.
The Bucks would boycott the game
after police shot and
paralyzed Jacob Blake
in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
The other teams in the bubble
in Orlando followed suit
and NBA playoff games came to a halt
along with most of the
rest of the sports world,
from major league baseball to pro tennis.
All eyes turned to the
NBA for the next move.
The Milwaukee Bucks were the team
that decided they weren't going to play,
but it also took the rest of our leagues,
the rest of our league
and the rest of the teams
that were playing that day
to make that same decision.
This is Lloyd Pierce.
During the 2020 season,
he was the head coach
for the Atlanta Hawks.
This was in essence,
the moment that we were preparing for.
We had had our meetings as
coaches and trying to strategize
on what we could do best
to support our players
when the time was right.
Well, that was the time,
that was the moment
The Hawks, of course,
weren't in the NBA bubble
at the time, having missed the playoffs
for the third year in a row.
Have I mentioned that it's a little tough
to be an Atlanta sports fan,
but The Hawks from afar,
ended up playing a critical
role in the negotiations
between the owners, the
league and the players.
Two key agreements emerged.
First, the league would
set up a new committee
on racial justice and Coach
Pierce would head it up.
I think the direct measure of
what we wanna do is leverage
what we can do as a league
with all of our owners,
all of our players, all of our coaches
so that we can take the
action and the conversation
from Orlando and amplify it into its real,
tangible, direct action in our
community and in our country.
The second thing spoke
directly to the voting issue
which had become the most
tangible form of activism.
Any NBA facility that could,
would become a voting center.
And The Hawks had the blueprint.
We had a lot of NBA teams,
whether it's from the strike.
There were a lot of teams
that had been working on it
prior to the strike.
It was really encouraging to
see a lot of the organizations
and the teams that represent
this country stand up
and provide that same
opportunity across the country.
There were several teams who
had wanted to do something
in their community, and really
hadn't decided what to do.
And it was just great communication
between team presidents
that we sent out our
schematic and our budget.
And, you know, the biggest
line item was security
'cause you had to have a
lot of security this year.
I mean that was the most,
the highest expense.
More than 40 sports arenas
in the US were ultimately converted
to polling places during
the 2020 elections
and some 300,000 people
around the country were able
to vote in the general election
at NBA facilities alone.
About 40,000 of those votes were all cast
in State Farm Arena.
Now keep in mind, the
presidential election in the state
of Georgia was decided by
less than 15,000 votes.
I think we really did create
sort of the largest, safest,
most efficient polling location
this country had ever seen.
I think the responsibility
from my perspective is really
to be a good community asset,
to be hopefully a great
business, a great franchise,
win basketball games
and be a really positive
member of the community.
And when both US Senate
races would require a runoff
which would determine
control of the US Senate,
this time The Hawks would
be joined by The Falcons
and their home, Mercedes-Benz Stadium.
When walked the stadium floor
and I've walked our
stadium thousands of times
as part of my job description.
This is Steve Cannon,
he's the CEO of AMB
Sports and Entertainment.
The parent company that
Falcons in Atlanta United.
He oversaw the election
process at Mercedes-Benz
which would split duty
with State Farm Arena
as a super polling location.
But to come in on that
early voting exercise
right where our stadium was transformed
for a special purpose
in an important moment
and to see how beautifully it ran.
It was laid out well.
There was a buzz and
conversations around our business
among our associates.
Hey, have you early voted yet?
And how was your wait time?
It was amazing that we were buzzing
about this election moment because I feel
like we've all recognized
the stakes of voting.
And tell me a little bit
about the fans in this regard
who I dare say, you know,
reflect the changing
demographics of Atlanta.
And I mean, there is an
element I would imagine
to this that is enlightened self-interest.
You wanna keep your fan base happy
and reflect their values
and their wants and needs.
Tell me about that.
Well, at the end, people do business
with entities that they like,
they care about and that they feel reflect
and share their values and businesses
that do that will enjoy increasing
success with the mindset
of this younger consumer that frankly
right now is coming of age
and are the most powerful
consuming cohort out there.
The shift on the part of the
owners to not just embracing
but encouraging activism,
can't be overstated.
It has spread to the college
and even the high school level.
It's also a reminder to those owners
that this isn't just any old asset.
So Tony, as an owner, it
feels like you witnessed
a really important moment,
a shift of sorts when it
comes to player empowerment,
in terms of activism, in
terms of having a voice,
it's not just tolerated
anymore, it's really expected.
Listen, people live in the community
that they play in, that they work in,
that they contribute to.
80% of NBA players are African-American.
These are our business partners.
So to me, we should try
to help support our business partners
in any way possible and our community.
The idea of having a voice
and the idea of being
good business partners
and the idea of standing up
for what you think is right.
I think that's all part
of what the NBA is trying to achieve.
In the runoff, Kelly Loeffler of course,
lost that Senate seat.
She ultimately decided
as well to sell her stake
in the Atlanta Dream.
And Renee Montgomery would
go from player to part owner.
You know, it felt good to be again,
a part of the right side of history
where black women, you know,
there's a lot of black women in the WMBA.
You know, majority of
the league is minority.
We understand the struggle.
I think the days of kind
of shut up and play,
you're here for our entertainment.
Those days are over
and that genie's never going back
in the bottle and that's okay.
And let's accept and celebrate it.
The opportunity here
and the exciting part is
that black voters in Georgia got a taste
of what that feels like when you are able
to flex your muscle and decide
who your leaders are gonna be.
2020, as we like to say
at More Than a Vote was
just the tip off of our work.
In fact, just a few months later,
as LeBron and the rest
of the NBA were headed
to Atlanta for the All-Star Game,
the GOP controlled legislature
in Georgia was aiming
to roll back some of the efforts
that made it easier to vote in the state.
One of the key activists,
former Senator and former
Dream owner Kelly Loeffler.
We don't know what's
gonna happen from here,
but we understand things
that need to be fixed.
You know, we're part of a system
that probably needs to be fixed.
So we get it.
We get the idea of, you know,
we have these platforms
and we're gonna use them.
Well by now my bias
toward Atlanta is clear,
but there is a massive story here.
It's undeniable that something new
and important happened in the past year.
The fact that it happened in
Atlanta shouldn't be a surprise
to anyone who knows its history,
its economics, its
demographics and its politics.
But few could have predicted
that sports would play such a key role.
Former Senator Loeffler,
remember she said,
there should be less politics in sports.
Having looked into this,
I think it's fair to say
there's gonna be more.
What happened in Atlanta
says something bigger,
something about sports
and business and culture
and how they're inextricably intertwined
in a new and different way.
It's a complicated world to be sure,
but it sure is fascinating.
Thanks so much for watching.
Would love to hear what you think
about this and other episodes
about the business of sports.
I'll be in the comments section.
Can't wait to hear what you think.